I feel extremely grateful for
the relationship that I was in last year
I managed to get my way to a point where
I Not only was known by a person that I
thought was the hottest alive but pulled
his ass yeah Billy eilish praising both
her ex Matthew Tyler vorce and new
boyfriend Jesse Rutherford dude here's
the thing bro the Grammy winner sat down
for an interview with Vanity Fair and
she's spilling some details on her love
life we're all just doing our thing you
know what I'm saying it all started
after Billy watched this flashback a
mashup of her answers about her
relationship status over the years no I
don't like dating at all no no
no
no
thank you no I don't have a boyfriend
I ca I could not have a boyfriend that
would just be mean to him I hate things
that aren't exclusive yep
yes I do that's when the 20 year old
made this confession I feel extremely
grateful for
the relationship that I was in last year
and I think he's
so much happier now which makes me
really happy Billy and Matthew dated
briefly in April 2021 calling things off
a year later fast forward to October of
this year the singers found herself a
new man if eggs
[Music]
Billy and the neighborhood singer Jesse
first sparked romance rumors after
hitting up Universal Studios Halloween
Horror Nights and after making their red
carpet debut earlier this month bill is
sharing insight into their relationship
it's really cool and I'm really excited
and I'm really happy about it I managed
to get my way to a point in my life my
life to a point where
I Not only was known by a person that I
thought was the hottest alive but pulled
his ass are you kidding me
the singer who's been known to be
private about her love life Raves over
her man but not without a little pat on
the back can we just
run with a blast for me
thank you
Jesse run the hood everyone
I pulled his ass all me I did that
I like that [ __ ] down
and while we are loving this glimpse
into Billy's World it seems we won't be
getting any more confessions from her
anytime soon Billy shared this to her
Instagram story revealing this video
interview would be her last for a while
but in the meantime we're finding out
what the singer looks for when it comes
to love my whatever they say love
language is just physical touch I just
need to be touching skin all the time
touching and cuddling and hugging and
other than that just like freedom
you know I don't want to be controlled I
want to be trusted and I want to be able
to have space and I want love and and
attention and
equal admiration is really important
[Music]